well hello how you doing silly I'm doing
good how are you
it is Monday another weekend has passed
and it is Sims and left go time
oh hello hey Chris nice shirt you have
on what do you think of this fancy old
thing seventy it is the Sims 70 shirt
we've been talking about this for a long
time about finally getting merchandise
for Sims and left oh this is the first
of a number that are coming that I'm
very excited about I haven't seen any of
these so this I just saw these the other
day for the first time so it's cool I'll
be sporting one here soon it says the
sim 70 and on the back wouldn't you know
what in jindo 1 through 70 all the
quarterbacks that you listed ending and
it's only their first day like we did
the first name telling number 70 Blake
cava Jax hello Blake comma Jax I need
can you turn the volume up on my
earphones more I think there's a little
still not going up loud enough I would
like to hear you more ok well of course
it's the only time of the week I want to
hear yeah it's funny I listened to the
podcast last Wednesday one I'd like to
hear myself less are you ready to have
to rank 70 quarterbacks every year
that's the I actually that's what I was
is that what I'm going to have to do for
now on we made the t-shirts oh yeah
you're gonna have to do 70 quarterbacks
every year ok I think it's a fun I can
deal with it once I've made the original
70 it's not that hard after that it's
gonna be the new guys I gotta somehow
fit them in right but at least I have a
basic guideline to go off let me start
at what week 14 that's when we're gonna
start is that what we want to do I don't
know you're just making this [ __ ] up on
the floor yeah ok good I know yeah I
mean it would've never happened if it
weren't for you I mean that would have
never happened thanks for putting more
work on my plate out of love go that's
what I do it was like that because I'm
putting more work on your plate I'd like
to give you a reward
oh I saw this over the weekend and
listeners of Sims and left go for a long
time know that we had a joke that we
would try and do to each other and try
to do to guests what was it who DS no
yes and somebody that got no better I
want to take you to Reming
didn't Park in Oklahoma City this is the
perfect place to start the podcast
welcome to the races Chris Sims cage
fighter both of these nuts they come
away together both of these nuts goes
from the front going away easily and df9
you see three green right there running
third outside bang bang you're gone
making some headway final hundred yards
both of these types cage fighter trying
to battle back both of these nuts cage
fighter both of these nuts rolling to
victory both of these that you haven't
seen these nuts before
isn't that the dream the dream is to
name a horse so ridiculous that it
finishes that the Matt the race but yeah
we used to do deez nuts to each other
the time but the fact that he horse
named both of these nuts won props to
that got props to that guy I don't even
know how to feel about that why that was
Oklahoma that's where we are I think in
the city it's just I don't know that's
just too much that's too much for me Tim
why didn't you like hey it's in the
world I want everything to be correct
right down in the sports world that
that's and that's derogatory to remind
us I thought you know it's funny it's
cool I get it I don't know I don't of me
that thinks damn kids are watching that
but I guess maybe they're not really
watching that one Wow speaking of kids
Phillip Sims Phillips them is he getting
scholarship offers yet no video of him
throw the footballs great that's what I
do now my weekends are no longer for
myself I just drive around my [ __ ]
kids and go to events that's all I do
you still want to be Eli um no I don't
think he does I think if there was this
favorite quarter I think his favorite
quarterback Russell Wilson right now
Russell Wilson that was the guy he
wanted to know it was coming on our
podcast during the Super Bowl
Russell Wilson when he found out Russell
would canceled and that was he was done
with us he didn't want to he does have
he wore the Russell Wilson jersey the
last time yes there he was all set curry
like because it's basketball season so
he's obsessed with that yeah but you
know what's hilarious is that he walked
I mean the kids are obsessed with
YouTube and everything else he watches
like all their social stuff and he's
come back to go LeBron's cooler on
social so I like LeBron more he seems
like a better dad he's more fun now he
likes LeBron back and he's back to
LeBron because of social that is a huge
one
some amazing responses this weekend of
whoa big offseason got this the DMC I
respond to most of these one person said
one of the guys at work just quit and on
the way out he says whoa big offseason
and I responded shut the F up like I
don't believe you and he said I'm not
kidding dude was happy as hell he binge
tapaa when I told him a few weeks ago we
were sitting around the office he quits
and boom whoa big losses incredible next
one
my girlfriend breaks up to me I'm not
gonna say this guy's name and I actually
whispered to myself why can't he say his
name Paco I didn't want to upset him
okay apparently his girlfriend broke up
with him and he said under his breath
whoa my wife has been saying it to me
lately she doesn't listen to a podcast
fully through I think she just listens
at times just to make sure I didn't tell
like an embarrassing story about her cuz
she doesn't know what I'm gonna say but
she's had a few moments in the last week
where she said whoa and then she hadn't
followed it with big offseason I was
like what you dork
get outta here
so I have a little problem you know
let's dive into the Sims household right
my wife we've talked about this before
she she snores and it's how I did not
realize yeah what you didn't never
realize this she snores like a 300-pound
left guard I mean truly roomed with
300-pound left guards they don't fool
around yeah yes it's horrible and my
wife Sicilian stubborn as hell it's my
problem that I hear her that's it's my
problem you get the sleep doctors meet
up with the stuff in her nose or in her
mouth I mean I've do everything I mean I
try to proper head up tell her Roller I
have a noise machine next to my bed that
goes
so I can't hear later - why bananas -
what I need I wear earplugs on him but
does she do the mouth guard uh she
doesn't she's done the Breathe Right
knows things nothing can stop her she is
nothing could stop her she's going to
snow yes she's a 300-pound Italian
grandma and now it's reached the point
where you complain so much that she's
upset at you complaining she's
graduation it's my fault so like I'm at
the point where I want her I don't want
to sleep with her anymore
yeah I wanted to move into the next room
trying to come and live with me so now
if they had absolutely not because I
sleep in the office but I think what I'm
going to do though because - sharing
this by the way this is great great she
calls like she like doesn't believe
everybody tells her how bad of her snore
is but when we get in these arguments
she doesn't believe it right so I think
what I'm gonna do for the podcast go PR
I'm gonna start I'm gonna start filming
her snore and I'm playing it on the
podcast are you sure I am are we sure I
am sure I am sure definitely all right
so you wanna first do you want a sound
bite yeah I think I have a sound bite
somewhere in there just invented a new
segment called shows his wife snoring
you sure you want to do this yeah screw
my wife let's see let's see let's just
see if it plays in the mic here here we
go I think this is one is this from when
is this from this is last summer wow you
sure you want this to go out of the
podcast 100% you're sure this is June
whoa big offseason it's my marriage and
if I choose to get divorced I'll choose
it you'll be doing some self scouting
yes no I think we should make this a
segment I'm dead serious
I think you just did okay good all right
so self scouting a lot of people came
back when you said the other day we're
talking about who's the fastest guy in
the NFL and is it Tyree kill oh and you
said well there's no running backs
people sent me out the wazoo a the
statistics of who hit the highest miles
per hour right of all the players in the
NF Oh Jay no Leonard fournette did
Leonard fournette had that to toe to
right the Pittsburgh game the 90-yard
touchdown only at a 75 yard touchdown
against the RAM right there the top
highest to right then it went martavis
Bryant Marquis Goodwin Tyree killed
Derrick Henry William Jackson taywan
taylor why is Leonard fournette not the
fastest guy hit the how fastest miles
per hour it's a good question I don't
think he'll scout I know we wrong
well top-end speed doesn't mean he
necessarily wins the 40 I mean right
it's about getting out for Nick to get
the highest but those guys have the
strongest 40 total I would say I don't
know if you do these statistics and I
lied I'm still betting on Tyreke kill
and I'm still betting on Odell Beckham
jr. I am you know also - you got to take
into account right with like people like
Tyree killing Odell Beckham jr. when
these things go into this like we're
recording your miles per hour let's not
forget they've run like 25 deep posts
and another 10 go routes to where
they're running back hasn't really had
to open up and run 60 or 70 yard
Sprint's the whole game even though he
had 20 carries he didn't have 20 long
stride I would say that would could be
part of that that would be my argument
right okay so I hear you listen they're
in the race I'm just saying from my eye
I don't think they're as fast as Tyree
killer Odell Beckham jr. maybe I'm still
shocked that Fernet had the fastest
speed because I didn't even think he
looked that fast when he was running but
we knew it because I remember we talked
about it during the season because we
were I don't know how we got on the
subject but I know you always said when
he was at LSU all I see when I turn on
the tape is he's outrunning SEC guys for
80 yard touch this freak of nature I'm
just saying I don't I don't think he's
fast as that maybe I'm wrong I don't
know I don't know but I know it's 40
wasn't as fast as those guys it's just
more proof than the NFL Pro Bowl should
just be people racing each other the
most and throwing far yeah but the
further Josh Allen let's see the most
impressive thing about things like that
- this is where I think a lot of sports
fans is football fans because I say
these things to my friends sometimes
like oh yeah I didn't even think about
that
nobody can catch on Leonard fournette or
a Tyree kill and they have a ball in
their hand and that's a big difference
like people forget that it's taking yes
running with a ball is gonna make you
slower so that's why probably LeSean
McCoy runs with it except that's like
how Joey Galloway it was almost more
baton for track and field instead of
having to tuck it away you can still use
your motion a little bit exactly right
so that's where I was always amazed it's
like it's like it's like there's a 40
and then there's 40 while dribbling a
basketball right right well so wisp
Russell Westbrook's could be a lot
faster than everybody I agreed 100% oh
one other thing that I need anybody else
in that conversation for like fastest
for anybody's Goodwin Tyree killed Derek
Henry was we know did we not add marques
Goodwin in the conversation but Derek
Henry being up yeah yeah he probably
showed Manderley was in the top 10 15 so
Chris Thompson Elijah McGuire hmm
Travis Benjamin made it in there Tyree
kills names on here like four or five
times I would think all those guys are
in the conversation and taewon Taylor
hmm I mean I just don't think they're
quite in the class of the other guys but
I'm not saying I'm the bill
I had the what am I trying to say I
don't know what I'm saying let's go you
sure yeah I'm gonna try and fix that one
other thing I'd like to self scout one
take that Sims has had for a very long
time is that if Americans specifically
NFL and NBA players were to train their
entire lives for soccer hmm they would
win the world cup domination well the
World Cup starts in about a week and a
half yeah and I just want to see if you
think Julio Jones would make your team
here is Julio Jones I'll post the full
video on YouTube here's Willie Jones
playing kickball impossible so is Julio
Jones on your World Cup team I mean
after that no but that I mean my point
of that conversation is if these guys
got to play this sport from a young age
like all of Europe or South America that
yes and our best best athletes like
these other countries played these
sports yeah we would dominate so even
though Messi and Ronaldo
they're awesome yes they're awesome but
no I still don't think they're that if
Odell Beckham grew up only playing
soccer
I mean Odell Beckham jr. is okay bigger
than Messi he's faster he's quicker
there's nothing that you could say
physically that he could do better other
than I understand can kick a ball better
well yes because he's done it more
okay yes I know Messi can't catch a ball
better though buddy I understand that
I'm saying so it's a learned skill and
I'm just saying if some of our athletes
which other international sports that
are best athletes are involved we
dominate so I don't know what others say
basketball when we want to win the gold
medal we went in every year boxing
oh we're I mean it's it's Oscar I can
feel track and field's 100 meters
burners 200 meters sprinters I mean it's
Americans and a few other countries
sprinkled in from time to time certainly
nobody from our planet nobody nobody
from Argentina in the hundred meter
final for the men any time soon neither
a Portugal and no nor have they been in
the medal stand in a long long time
Brazil's up there Brazil I am NOT in
sprinting I don't know tell me tell me
right Jamaica right this so that's all
I'm saying so how do we respect
like do we just start taking kids and go
listen don't balls dangerous let's play
soccer no I know there's nothing there's
nothing there's nothing that ever be
done we're gonna have to get a soccer
expert in here to kind of figure this
never agree what I need they'll never
agree what we're gonna do it's it's it
doesn't sound good to their sport there
is no great what agree with you and
that's why this debate isn't great
because I'm kind of like kind of agree
with you I kind of want a foot of
football I want a football versus
football debate you versus maybe someone
that's really a football and I just
wanna hear their reaction yeah ok it's
like I had this conversation with
Evander Holyfield in boxing right or I
just go you're losing all your he didn't
want to agree with it because he know
it's our youth youth programs that's
what the problem was with boxing and I
said no no it's it's you're all the
middle linebackers in football those are
the best heavyweights in the world
they're just playing football cuz I said
why would I sit there get punched in the
face when I can just lower my head and
deck people myself and it's actually a
safer career and so people play football
but yeah I don't know it's just the same
type of argument I think we're I mean
come on
I like the United States have you a
champs I mean we would have we have them
all so two things coming up on
Wednesdays pod one I'll have full
information about where you can get the
sim 70 shirts too we did this thing at
the office a few months ago called a
disc assessment and what it does is it
finds out whether you
are independent or you're determined and
all these things and everyone found to
be really accurate and the number one
question everyone asked what do you
think Sims is what is Sims gonna come up
on the chart and no one knew because
you're kind of a D you're a little bit
of an AI sometimes an S I'm having the
guy coming that's an assess the D is C
stands for something Dan for different
things D I was like [ __ ] you you're d
okay I'll explain it on Wednesday yeah
but I'll have you take the test tomorrow
and we're gonna find out Sims
personality on what your boy said you
had the second best announcer voice in
the whole office which person that's
what guys used to do that so this became
a thing on the sidelines like during
games and that was a backup I might have
told you this old okay but damn I'm
gonna forget his name but that's how
guys would get me during the game as a
backup quarterback like guys this guy I
used to play with come up and Mia hey
old boy said old boy said he's got a
better arm than you and is not affair
its third quarter of the game I'm trying
to write down place or gird it and
you're taking the rate it's a great
trick to say you're second best
yeah yeah yes right because then it
changes you know and then you're also
thinking about who is first faster right
who said that right a lot of who's
that's why I was hoping to get you there
I remember when I got Jadeveon Clowney
do you remember that story Jadeveon
Clowney were going to do a shoot with
him this is when I got the video where
he didn't know who Bill Belichick was
and that went a little viral I was like
two months in starting a bleacher report
and I go in there and he'd been doing a
shoot for coconut water all day and he
was exhausted like we got in there he
would have talked to us at all and
they're putting microphones on us and I
go Jadeveon man they say you're the
second best person ever pitched coconut
water and he said who everybody turned
and he got so upset and then he turned
to the makeup lady he said guess who was
talking about you and she was I ain't
fallin for that [ __ ]
[Music]
that's awesome Kyle Shanahan still
hasn't done anything this week what up
Kyle but Jon Gruden something did happen
Oh John Gurdon upstaging Shanahan and
the Bay Area Cruden is grinding this one
actually came from Donald Penn he was on
Michael Rapaport spod cast and as soon
as Colton Miller was drafted apparently
Donald Penn said I'm not gonna lie as
soon as I saw the draft pick I called
Gruden immediately like man what the
[ __ ] he didn't answer but when I saw him
the next Monday he was joking with me
and said what do you think Rudin said to
him before I reveal it ooh
how do you think Roone handled the
situation pissed you off I took a tackle
ha ha ha the first round huh to piss you
off fish off the correct answer was you
ready to kick my ass huh how does that
make you feel better and make you say
it's you've seen him do this before I
have I what does it remind you of I mean
I just know that he's done it to me
before whether we signed free agent
quarterbacks right take him out a little
bit make him mad we got too many
quarterbacks in the room yeah yeah 7
them [ __ ] we got 7 and we only have 70
plays at practice and we have seven
[ __ ] quarterbacks the [ __ ] yeah I'm
mad it's not passive-aggressive it's
almost like overtly aggressive its
overtly in-your-face we're trying to get
better as a team and you want to stay
onboard the ship then compete and here
we go
when does that turn two he's motivating
me and I don't even realize it
- I know he's trying to motivate me in
it's annoying it it won't get it it's
not gonna get annoying until you truly
feel like he can go over boy to where
you're gonna go oh he's not truly trying
to motivate me anymore he's getting
personal I mean he really doesn't like
me anymore that's when you're gonna
start to see that's what really happens
so he is gonna constantly push buttons
on players she's a master at doing that
especially if he's a guy like Donald who
he
prior relationship it was played with us
down in Tampa who knows the guy he knows
the makeup
he made Donald who he is he let him mate
he was an undrafted player that got to
be a franchise left tackle so he knows
what makes him tick so he's gonna push
those buttons to stop pushing buttons
it's like my old saying he when he stops
pushing buttons is when he's truly
stopped on you he's given up so you want
him coming in and be like yes you do
Wow that was my advice to derrick karr
like take it okay when you talk to Tara
button people always like what rejoinder
car like so listen just take it learn
football understand you're gonna get
cussed out even at times when you don't
deserve it
but know that the moment he stops
cussing at you and saying crazy [ __ ]
that's the means he's he's [ __ ]
abandon ship he's given up on you he
doesn't think you're worth a damn
anymore man that's when you know I mean
to me either playing training camp one
year he took me out on a full we were
doing an eleven eleven scrimmage at the
end of practice and I was I think this
was my second year and I was competing
to maybe be the starter right with Brad
Johnson like I think that was in his
brain and every rep was important I want
to start I didn't care and I had a bad
snap in 11 all 11 practice I mean the
ball didn't even it dribbled on the
ground and went through my legs but he
didn't really see it and he was gonna
blame it on me cuz that was the
quarterback and then I got so pissed him
he took me out of practice and I was
[ __ ] him left and right like
you MA and you know Joey Galia to come
over and calm me down but that's what he
does he didn't want to hear it he didn't
care you're the quarterback get it
looking back at it did it help
yeah it did why it all helped because it
just all made me tougher and made me
realize that you know what even though
it was a bad snap I'm the quarterback
I'm accountable
I got a mother [ __ ] the center I'm
saying a lot of f-words here today sorry
Joe sorry Joe but it made me realize
that I gotta take accountability to to
being even a leader and staying on top
of the center the linemen whatever it
may be he was gonna hold me accountable
for it so that's where it made me better
all right let's hold Kyle Shanahan
accountable another wide receiver has
come out and says he wants to play
for the 49ers and he's ready to take the
veterans minimum Terrell Owens I heard
that I saw that yeah sorry sorry there's
no place for 44 year old receivers in
the NFL I want him back
I know you do why because I he he to me
looks like he can physically do it I
understand that he passes the eye I've
had people this is where I think he does
he passes the eye test his top-end speed
is probably still like NFL but like
slightly average or below NFL average
receiver the thing where people lose at
that age is the twitchiness right the
ability to be able to oh the ball
snapped let me split my feet and then
let me make an explosive move by also
slapping a guy's hands out of the way as
I accelerate the top speed within three
steps to start my route those are the
little things that those guys miss and
lose out on when they get to that age do
you think there is any team in the NFL
that has even thought about bringing
Terrell Owens back absolutely not really
no like no one's even having the
discussion no he's he's he's that it
didn't partly that's his fault he's
burning those bridges it's just like
it's just like we talked about with any
of those guys right left go I mean it's
just like damn what what do we want to
bring him in here by oh so we can have a
44 year old receiver come in here and
catch 17 balls but have 17 distractions
and press conferences - yeah that's what
we want him on our team mmm I mean that
would be there's nothing he could do or
say to get another chance I don't think
so
no man yeah she watching a Johnny
Manziel over the weekend no I did not
it's pretty for 10 something lights 8
for 10 right yeah yeah all right I'll
check out the next one I didn't see the
highlights yet I got so I thinking I'm
thinking maybe for Wednesday out we'll
have you look over the highlights we can
play on the YouTube I'm interested to
see because I know the reviews from like
his a AFL practices in that they were
not good from NFL people I don't want to
give away my take okay but the one play
that was circulating on Instagram that
was really great I was like that
defensive em was closing on him way too
fast I'll look at the highlights so I
can do that all right cool all right
let's get to the real contract things
that are continuously ongoing one is
Odell Beckham's
Jr the first giant mandatory minicamp
starts next Tuesday
well Odell Beckham was not a tote EA's
today but Pat Shermer did say that he
should be cleared by next week
are you expecting Odell to be at the
mandatory minicamp on Tuesday I am
expecting him to be there yes I expect
him to do nothing more than individual
drills in practice that's what I would
say that's the play to me go there and
show your face again be in the meetings
go out to practice take part of warmups
if you're cleared take me through the
first day of mandatory minicamp
mandatory minicamp is getting there at
what time yeah we're getting there
you're getting there 6:30 7:00 in the
morning and we're going right to the
meeting room you're probably gonna have
like drop your shirt at the lock at 7:30
special teams meeting and probably eight
o'clock offense and defensive meetings
right the special team is kind of get
everybody on board feel real good here
the lay of the land here's kickoff or
whatever gonna work on today here's
kickoff basic alignment basic what we're
gonna work on guy rich passaggio I've
seen on All or Nothing right he makes
everyone shake everybody's hand and he's
playing like happy and all that stance
everybody's energy and the right teams
meeting seems like the most fun meeting
it mean it's usually the most energetic
coach on the staff quarterbacks go to
special teams meeting only in New
England yeah that was my first my only
taste of it ever was in Denver when I
played for Josh McDaniels maybe New
Orleans with Taysom Hill yeah yeah right
but yet that was the only ones where
they wanted the whole team in there for
special teams meetings not every special
teams anything but when they had like
the day after the game special teams
meeting quarterback had to be in there
better or worse with the quarterback to
the meeting doesn't really change any it
no it doesn't change anything other than
that I just found it fascinating to know
who to hold accountable on some of the
special teams plays that I never knew
before or I would learn about other
teams special teams players where I go
damn I didn't know that guy was so good
at the specialist teams holy crap that's
why he's been around for nine years he
doesn't even play a position
Sean Morey right right yeah I mean
that's where you learned about some of
those gems where you go holy cow there
their whole punt cover team is based
around one guy freeing him up to go down
to make a tackle Mack Holland's for the
Eagles yes find a way Brian tackling let
them loose right right so you go to the
offense defense meeting up and then
we're
you're gonna have meetings meetings
meetings probably til tributyl 11 or
11:30 the thing I don't know about with
mini camps anymore they allow their two
days anymore and many kids doubt it I
know you're not right so you're gonna do
meetings so about 11:00 or 11:30 in the
phrase two a day as bands I know you're
right didn't mean it is I mean my day
you did two days during mini camp back
in my day I was twice for the Sun I
would drink water off the dripping sweat
of my teammate because I couldn't have
it was it's crazy that I'm saying it is
crazy that it's like a decade ago and it
feels like five we did two days every
day I mean we did a going back to it yes
so now you have the meetings they have
mini camp yeah you're just gonna be what
do you what do you look doing in all
these meetings on the first day it's
just gonna be all it's so everything
you've learned at OTAs this is gonna be
more like a Wednesday practice in season
right we're installing we're installing
we're gonna press the boundaries a
little bit with some new stuff and
you're allowed to be a little more
physical in practice during mini camps
all of those things so then you're gonna
go out and have a real walkthrough at 11
o'clock where it's gonna be like here
we're gonna run these 40 plays against
these different defenses and see how
we're gonna walk through we're gonna
come in we're gonna eat lunch we're
gonna meet again we're gonna watch the
walkthrough on film and talk about some
more things you're gonna get out of that
you're gonna go get taped up and now
it's okay we're gonna go outside for a
2:30 or 3:00 o'clock practice so you're
do so the morning is meetings going over
things preparing to do things walk
through the walk through what we're
going to do right and then it's how big
of a lunch you have your it depends on
the first day the first day I think
everybody's probably nervous and just
gonna have something like chicken breast
and some broccoli like something like
that
is it nerves I mean yeah I think
everybody it is it's nerves cuz you're
just going damn I'm you know back and
being held accountable and I got to
perform and I got a coach worried you
know you everything you got to do
athleisure late for everything because
they always have to be on time for
everything in their life how different
is it if it's a new coach or if it's the
same new coaches way more intense
changes first of all you can have too
many camps right your offseason stinks
because you have extra OTAs you're the
extra
minicam and yeah the new head coach is
trying to make his imprint and he wants
everything to get off to a good start
wants to impress the owner and the GM
everything so yeah that's a different
offseason like where are you are you
looking around at lunch and check it out
people's arms and how they've done the
offseason or did you already do that no
to you yeah you already did that in the
OTAs but now you're getting some guys
back who haven't been there like some of
the stars are back in the locker room
and you're starting to realize like man
this this locker room is different no
more in snaps walking around and when he
wasn't you know was like damn Fletcher
Cox is here right he is huge and Tim he
is loud and it didn't change the whole
dynamic the whole locker rooms loud now
cuz all the alpha males are back you
almost have like a leadership dynamic
and OTA right that when minicam happens
can get turned on at a can especially
it's like Tom Brady and Gronkowski show
up where an apple Edelman was leading it
for two weeks and now Brady now all of a
sudden Edelman is not talking as my
exactly what does that do to the young
guys it just it's just another
experience for them in the NFL the NFL
is fascinating when you're young cuz
you're still like so used to high school
in college and you're like man they
treat me like a man
they cussed me out like a man when they
leave I get to do whatever I want as
long as I don't get in trouble they
don't care so all these freedoms yet
you're at football all day long and now
you're starting to meet your idols and
these guys you've watched on TV forever
and you are you're starstruck you're a
receiver it's the first time you're
running routes and all sudden you go
holy Sh I'm about to run a slant route
for Tom Brady like that does I was
around football my whole life and I was
at a practice come on damn I'm about to
catch a ball from Tom Brady in warm-ups
this is pretty cool I mean so I'm doing
and I know they're doing it yeah so 2:30
to go on the field is it individuals
first it's it's it's a another fake way
to walk through to act like we're not
really practicing the coaches are
manipulators no practices only twelve
periods but you look at it it's like
twelve
ten-minute periods but yet we have like
these seven periods of walkthroughs in
between here and there oh and coach
didn't count three of the individual
drills on the practice
it's you know you look at the schedule
of practice you go it's only an hour in
20 minutes but if you're really out
there for two and a half hours because
of they'll walk through it some of the
individual drills I just want to know
when is Odell gonna be working out and
when are we gonna see him on the side oh
yeah you're gonna see them on so at the
start of practice it's gonna be walk
through you start to gradually okay we
walk through now we stretch and warm up
now we're gonna go to individual drills
you're gonna see him do all that stuff
then it's gonna come together probably
at seven on seven and that's when Odell
should go coach coach you guys aren't
paying me crap I'm gonna go sit over
here I'm being paid like a child and I'm
one of the best players in football I'll
be on the sidelines watching good luck
that's how you've seen someone do
individual drills and pull themselves
out of team before yeah yeah
like Simeon rice could do stuff like
that in Tampa I mean he was out in the
contract negotiation he was just he said
above he was above it and he was like he
would he would he might tell John like
hey I'm I'm gonna get after it after
practice today I don't want to get off
them I don't want to get down and get
off the leg I'm gonna train I'm here for
individual I'm gonna do some work with
Marinelli after practice but then after
practice
I'm gonna run sprints you're gonna see
me out here for like an hour and a half
pulling sleds and pulling parachutes and
then he's gonna go in there and power
clean and do all those things too so
Odell's obviously not gonna go you're
not paying me enough though what does he
do he's gonna have this conversation
with property ownership and patch
Shermer before the minicamp starts to
just lay it down like hey you know I
he's I'm sure the agents gonna call to
give the ownership and the head coach a
little bit of like this is what we're
thinking Sims what if he ends up doing
sevens man I'll be so disappointed and
we're just gonna have to sit here and
tell him how disappointed we are now and
then we're gonna have to keep our
fingers crossed that he doesn't get hurt
yeah to all the people that have filled
out the expect net baby pool were well
over 300 now of guesses I'd like to say
apologies to Greg from the United
Kingdom see you Greg Benedict from
Germany by Benedict David Beresford from
United Kingdom sorry David he's the one
thing this Tebow is better than sim oh
how dare you of okay gosh
Ian Jones from Chesapeake Beach Maryland
and Andrew Victor of Huntington New York
he said this competition was brought to
you by long [ __ ]
all of you guessed that Odell will have
gotten his new contract by now he has
not again head over to expect net and
enter the game named obj contract for
your chance to guess when Odell gets his
contract we when is yours
wait so you said we learn training camp
that's not mini camp no that's not mini
camp that's mini camp this is training
kit yeah I'm saying it goes into July
whatever that day they officially say
we're opening camp up it's gonna be that
third day which I don't think they've
said because I looked up I can't find it
anyway yeah I don't think they've
officially started that day yet I'm
amazed what I'm amazed by first of all
by our rude England listener who thinks
Tim Tebow is better than me David but
Beresford
but the I've always faster days like
with our guys from the UK or Germany
like do they find the contract situation
I'd love to hear comments or then like
our contract situation in the NFL do
they find it like absurd and crazy
that's somebody like Odell Beckham jr.
who's you know our version of Shrine
Steiger or some other good soccer player
isn't getting paid doesn't get paid
guaranteed money I would love to hear
their thoughts passionately when you
think about a guy like a name or a
Ronaldo who's gonna get like 500 million
dollars and then to switch teams
one team is spending like 200 million to
get the rights to him
yeah same well I mean it's you know that
that is up there Major League Baseball
MBA that's why we're the players podcast
yes because we're the only sport that in
which you have no leverage and no
control yeah and the only way you do is
by not playing right and that's all we
ask
I thought there is a good nickname
though coming from New York Giants Camp
jeer the nickname for say Kwan Barclay
no Odell is calling him say quads sake
say Kwas barkley say quads came out and
said I don't like it no what else said
you're gonna take it good I like it
that's that's what you do you put a
rookie in his place
do we need to adopt that name or should
we wait tell them say Kwas or should we
wait I think we let's let that ride for
a little those are so if anybody
deserves a nickname of their hamstrings
and quads and ass it's him legs and ass
man we got some people suggesting what
we're gonna say
I said maybe we should come up with our
own nickname playing into the legs like
he can take the quad part can we get the
butt part like you know I don't know
what the creative you're more creative
than me they ought to think about yeah
but other people submitted some legs and
asks for the legs and a steam and we'll
have to make this more efficient Kwan
ake a squat him Kwan a curly Evan said
Khalil McKenzie should be on the all
legs and a steam that's Reggie son that
guy trapped in a Tennessee I've never
seen legs look like that they're
unbelievable Wow
Akeem Hicks was suggested to us yeah
Andy Bell also said David and Joe ku
four legs and a steam it's pretty good
Dave and joke oh yeah it is it's pretty
impressive I mean who was the one they
said before that
Khalil McKenzie no Khalil McKenzie and
then a akim akim akim Hicks didn't you
see him in person man he mixes
definitely on the doesn't get enough
respect team yes he's like he was
unbelievable hey where's yes another
contract this one's more interesting
Gera folow reported that Rogers once
quote some sort of an out clause that
would allow him to renegotiate the deal
if and when it's leapfrog by other
quarterbacks
so of course Rogers had his New Deal
that was twenty two million a year and
since then he's been jumped by luck car
Stafford Garoppolo Cousins and Ryan and
it sounds like in this new deal he once
an out clause so that if he gets someone
with a higher salary I don't know I'd
like to renegotiate we just saw Kirk
Cousins change contracts forever in my
opinion right with getting a fully
guaranteed 84 million dollar contract is
Rodgers going to be the one that gets an
out clause do you think that this
happens I do think that this is the type
of guy that can change the rules like
even more than occur cuz it's like
because the quarterback we know can
change the rules right but when you're
the superstar of the league like a
Rogers okay or maybe Russell Wilson or
Brady if it was his prime whatever those
are the type of guys that can get these
things change or and be a true
trendsetter for the rest of the NFL yeah
I don't think it's crazy for Aaron
Rodgers whether it's one to say I have
to be paid one of like one of the three
tuyas pay
quarterbacks in the league at all times
until the age of 37 or 38 that's why
that could be one thing look which
coaches get that stuff all the time
I mean Mack Brown when I was at Texas
how to be one of the five highest-paid
coaches in college football he had to be
was in his contract so I'd see Bob
Stoops and her and I are gonna new deal
and I got a damn here goes Mack I'm
gonna get more money Wow you know you
even know you know Newton this guy got
New Deal this guy got a new deal look
this guy's a nuclear so I do think that
can happen or we're gonna see the
percentage of the salary cap thing
happened with a guy like Rodgers I think
that is this kind of thing he can wear I
can he can go flat rate
I deserve 25 percent of the salary cap
every year do you think we've always
said that it takes the big-name
quarterbacks to really impact anything
yes Lee yeah I've long said if Aaron
Rodgers kneeled before the anthem we
might actually have a conversation right
right Steven be like whoa well it's
spreading to Aaron Rodgers but in terms
of salary are they helping the league by
simply getting more money yeah are they
helping out everybody else does the
quarterback position get the runningback
position more money or does it just get
the quarterback position more money I do
think it helps everybody the contracts
but I would also argue that it's they
get too much to like you know I mean
it's back to her right are they taking
away right like Kirk Cousins I think
helped out quarterbacks in the future
yes I bet going he got guaranteed money
I would like guaranteed money
iving Rodgers with an opt-out clause or
a percentage of salary cap will again
take quarterback levels to another level
I just don't know if it's helping the
rest of the league I don't know if it's
helping the middle guys isn't having is
it trickle down or is that all [ __ ]
I I think it's [ __ ] do you I do yeah
I think at the end of the day I mean I
still think the quarterback is being put
on a pedestal that's a little too high
even for my liking as an x-coordinate
Aaron though well he might be the
lowness well I mean he's amazing and he
certainly could break things but I mean
damn even Aaron Rodgers as amazing as he
is I mean he's still not worth five
Bobby wagner's or somebody like that I
don't care I mean this so that's where
it does annoy me a little bit because
and I think that's why you do see
resentment around
NFL with quarterback sometimes Emily I
know we've had this conversation because
guys in the locker room are sitting
there going damn I'm one of the best
linebackers in football and this
quarterback is not in one of the top
half quarterbacks in football and he's
making four times and not money I am and
I understand that's an important
position but I do think it's maybe
swayed a little bit in the wrong
direction I don't know if it's
necessarily helping everybody out the
quarterbacks being paid that much more
money than everybody else cancelling
that Sims shirt let me just tell you he
is the number one quarterback in the NFL
let's see it was it was Rodgers one
Wilson - when's three Brady four
Stafford five would that change it all
now nope that's my top five for right
now damn yeah
Carson Wentz by the way is he announced
this is how incredible this person is
yes
he created a 25-foot food truck that is
going to give away free food to people
that need it and the name of the truck
is thy kingdom Crum it's really good
he is Russell Wilson yeah except I'm not
annoyed by him yeah he's my quarterback
that's really what it is speaking of
food let's do some beans not beef Baines
not beef the Colts asked Henry Anderson
to lose 25 pounds to play in their
defensive scheme yeah and now he's on
the Jets and they won on the gain those
25 pounds back that's rough man
that was the shitty part he told in New
York Daily News but it's part of the
business I guess so for nearly three
months he worked out for four hours a
day and ate a restricted diet he was
putting on 20,000 calories a day a 30%
reduction I didn't eat a lot I ate the
same thing every day nothing but fish
chicken brown rice and vegetables all
offseason to get down to that weight and
now he's saying that he's not going to
just start eating like crap to put it up
back on because he sees the benefit so
he wants to be smart
the only benefit his wife apparently
likes him a little bigger oh she likes
him a little bigger huh a little bit
more plump a little more plum have you
ever been around people that have had to
do the extreme weight loss weight games
on a football team
not extreme I I mean we had a lot of
guys I'm whether I was in New England I
mean I'm you know Vince Wilfork on
Thursday morning 6:30 he was sitting in
the sauna because he knew he had away
and he had to make weight or he's gonna
lose money I mean I thought that's like
coming for a test it is right so the
extreme weight loss thing I can't say
that I have because I I never was a part
of that right so Henry Anderson was in
this 3-4 scheme they signed the new
defensive coordinator who has a Dallas
scheme which is for three it's more
speed better predicated so he's trying
to be a good soldier and fit within the
siege on the Jets now I know I'm gonna
happen to the Colts then he gets traded
to the Jets and the Jets go hey we run
in a 3-4 we need you to get back to
where you were and that's it's brutal
first of all for guys like that to lose
that kind of weight you know again this
is where I push back against the
narrative in the NFL that people are on
performance answering drugs all the time
now Henry at most people in the NFL are
losing trying and a loss a losing a
weight loss program they are naturally
enormous they're like this guy Henry
Anderson right like he's he's naturally
a big guy that yeah over time eating and
lifting weights he got to 295 now to get
him to 275 yeah or 270 that was brutal
but now he's transformed his body to go
back the other way again I mean that's a
lot of stress on your body doing that
sounds like he get really sick I mean it
can't be good for you no no of course
not but that's again the price of doing
business is there any chance that by
going down to 275 that when he builds it
back up to 295 will have a better family
good yeah he could yeah I mean he has
I'm sure he's smarter now than when he
was in high school in college when
people are just going oh I just got to
get bigger because that's what all guys
do when they're young I got tell I tell
Kyle our high school kids that now in
college I can stop worrying about being
big you're gonna get to the NFL one day
and you're gonna realize that
everybody's trying to lose weight and
become faster but yeah that that's a lot
I mean to ask of a guy and I'll be
interested to see if he can get back up
to 295 but I would think since he's
smarter this day and age yeah that he'd
be able to pack more my Stanford you
okay you having a hard time now button
cutting me off today can you tell that
I'm working I can really tell you've
like sat back like a few times like
it's interesting Chris it's hard yeah
it's cause because you're a [ __ ] big
mouth I know I'm trying to get better at
it
I didn't write selfs down and um do it I
don't even know it too but then I read
watched it and I was like oh man I knew
last week it was a little worse than
normal yeah and then Josh after texted
me he's like hey let go cut you off
Elias Oh Josh texted you you know let's
let's out him yeah Josh text me he goes
hey sorry love cool he apologized for me
t apologize for you cuz there's
something you're a jerk okay you cut me
off a lot but but I was like oh dude I
don't care I'm so used to it I was like
I did notice it a little more today than
usual but yeah Wednesday show was Adam
had nine pages of notes and a lot of
caffeine and you were gonna get cut off
that's what was gonna happen
let's go - whoa slow offseasons Oh
haven't done one of these yet Devante
Parker last year they came out and said
he was gonna be a monster I remember
that story well guess what two coaches
Jefferson and Christians and now in
different roles in the staff we were
making quote we were making these giant
claims about him last year now we're
just doing it one day at a time
mentality stacking good days on top of
each other so they Devante Parker who
I'm a big fan of was a whoa big
offseason last year realized maybe they
hyped him up too much and now they're
doing a slow slow whoa pump the brakes
yeah that's probably the proper approach
for a guy that hasn't accomplished what
he was what he's supposed to accomplish
as what was either the top 15 top 20
pick right at a Louisville he was
somewhere in that range
yeah been hurt there's been the
complaints there about what is not tough
enough to fight through injuries all of
those things have you been around
somebody they got really hyped up and
then after that had to like a Cadillac I
know I have Cadillac you didn't have to
worry about it Cadillac could yeah Mike
Clayton Mike that's a guy I know yep and
he fell in the trap and I think he would
tell you I'm not trying to talk bad
about him or anything like that but yeah
you're 21 years old and you got money in
your pocket then you had a great rookie
year everything was awesome and Joey
Galloway was hurt so Gordon had to do
more around Michael Clayton right
because we didn't have the weapon and
the offseason came around he was beat up
a little cuz he did take he was a
physical receiver so he took a little
time off yeah let a few weeks you know
become a month or six weeks a party and
having fun and eating too much yeah and
yeah he came back for a training camp
the next year it was like damn I mean
this was almost the Rookie of the Year
last year and this year I'm not sure
he's gonna start
I feel like Devante Parker and Josh
dachshund are in a similar boat when you
see what they're capable of yeah you go
oh my gosh Josh Thaksin could be a red
zone threat on every play like yeah he
dropped that ball against the Raiders
but like did you see him go up 44 inches
and get the ball those are the guys that
get turned on in the locker room quicker
than anybody what does that mean like
because everybody sees their talent and
yet they're not contributing to the team
the way they should and that starts the
negative kind of he's you know he's a
wuss he's a I mean he's just gonna blame
it on some they start to just look at
him in a negative because they go I've
seen him make all these amazing plays
and catches and yet when it comes time
to turn the lights on he can never play
or do anything or whatever it is and
that's where you start to get a bad rep
in the locker room because guys start to
talk bad about you behind your back
because we know what you're capable
right right that's I'm sure John Ross is
feeling it exactly exactly right all
right whoa big offseason turning down
money for greatness
Patrick mahomes Leigh Steinberg told
ESPN that the goal the first year was to
establish himself not get every
endorsement dollar quote we talked about
how the first year goal was to integrate
into the team and we didn't want to we
wanted to pay deference to the incumbent
veterans and try not to go into
situations with a high profile we
intentionally did not do endorsements
that would run in Kansas City you like
this this remind you of Tebow doesn't it
it was the first thing I thought it's
brilliant I mean that's what you should
do all right this is how you gain the
respect to the locker room then the
ninth year guard doesn't want to see
their rookie quarterback who hasn't done
crap for the Kansas City Chiefs on a
national commercial or even a local
commercial in a city okay just you don't
want to see it you got to gain respect
from the organization of the team
through your play on the field first
they want you've got to show people that
that's most important to you
and that's where you're headed in the
right direction when you do the other
stuff that's gonna make people question
you or when things go bad they're gonna
give that that's not gonna help with the
benefit of the doubt they're gonna go
well maybe he would have known his
playbook better if you didn't do those
for Nike commercials last May for no
reason right you know whatever it may be
so I think that is the right thing
Caskey my ear oh he did it he did a
commercial remember like after all the
years he came out he had liked the mat
and the thing with Russell Wilson and
all that stuff people like my name is
doing a lot of and a lot right yeah what
happens Krakow ski mod the year I'm
gonna lose my spleen he's a rookie and a
Toledo out of Toledo he did like a local
car dealership commercial in town and
yeah there was a number the coaches a
number of guys that were just like what
do you do it man like you're you're the
third string quarterback I just always
think of Tebow where Kyle Orton starting
and you talked about Tebow had there
were billboards all across town never
said anything about it did it was it
made himself available to the press
every day after practice those are
certain no nose in a locker room I don't
blame the rookies because I've seen them
at the NFLPA and the rookie premier and
after the they declared for the NFL
Draft other than training for the
combine the other thing they're doing is
media availability and fan stuff and
they're picking up quick $10,000 checks
everywhere sign these 3,000 cars yeah
do this right and their agent is like
dude we're just gonna Bank as many
$10,000 gigs as we can and they're going
all over the place so I can understand
why it's hard not to say yes or let's
say they shoot a commercial after the
draft and they don't even realize that
it's gonna start airing during training
camp right so I don't fault them a lot
but that's why you get the agents to
kind of go we're not doing this sir
especially last year
you know like for Patrick mahomes where
we knew Alex Smith was gonna be the
starter all year right right you don't
even mess with it don't mess with it and
it's like the kicker may feel doing ads
would be tough right now no doubt about
it no and just it's just not gonna give
you the benefit of the doubt in the
locker room that's all there is to it
it's not like the worst thing in the
world you know and again you know I
would say I get upset at a sake one who
we all knew
is going to be a face would youwould the
Giants can upset with say Quan I mean
he's got the face if he was over doing
it they would get they would get upset I
think yes guys like a sake one you know
they could get a free pass to do a
national commercial and things like that
because their physical ability is so
apparent to everybody everybody knows
they're going to be special and of
course quarterback is a little different
than any other position guy too
so there's a little don't think any of
the quarterbacks can do it no you can't
do it
Heisman runners I understand there
because there's the Heisman like Mariota
came out he had won the Heisman right so
we do the Heisman commercial understand
there's some of that right like I'm not
gonna blame Marcos Mejia compost at
already that's already a part of his
name and people are gonna understand
that within the locker room let's go to
whoa wait offseason Baker Mayfield yeah
Brown source tells me internally people
are continually blown away with Baker
Mayfield quote never have we seen
teammates gravitate to someone like this
I mean this guy must be keeping candy in
his pockets or something like what I
don't get it I don't get it either I
don't necessarily I've never heard this
as a description of some okay do my
first thing is what what do I want to
say about that comment why are we not
hearing any reports about him throwing
exactly right now I mean what we're
talking about how gravitationally is to
the locker just that's the thing that's
weird to me is I've never heard another
player where they talk about him like
he's the ice and cream man going down
the street yeah people just gotta walk
over and just touch him now the only
time that I've talked about that before
was when we would see Patrick mahomes or
someone really talented people would
just come up and like talk to him yeah
Baker it's it's this Pied Piper thing
that's Dylan it's real I think that he's
a really likable guy a great leader I
think all that's real just from
everybody I talked to in the pre-draft
process you know again what do you
expect New England I mean Cleveland to
say right I mean they're gonna say
something yeah but now it's the
reporters now they could say whatever
they want yeah you're right you're right
you're right that is a source internally
but who knows yes who knows another
rookie yeah whoa Lamar Jackson huh Eric
Weddle on Lamar Jackson quote he's been
great obviously you know why we took him
he's as talented of a player that I've
seen
coming into my 12th year he's got a live
arm and he can sling it yeah obviously
his ability to run and shake guys you
see it in team drills where things break
down he gets on the perimeter and guys
aren't even close to him whoa or oh I
think it's that I know a little
something about going on there and yeah
I mean just that the reviews are pretty
sky-high that the throwing is better
than they expected you know isn't it
perfect no but those kind of same things
to that it's very apparent to how
special this kid is as especially as an
athlete yeah because there has been a
few times I think he's broken out and
everybody's like damn we can't even two
in touch him out here so what are you
thinking what are you hearing from
Baltimore anything I mean I just mmm
yeah I still think a lots gonna be said
as far as just how preseason goes and
all that I still think Joe Flacco is
going to be the starter going into the
season but man if Baltimore which is a
team I think as pretty high expectations
if they start off the year like three
and three two and two and Joe's just
been average or below average if these
things continue to surface up these kind
of talk then that those are the things
that made me believe that ooh okay this
is getting out of the building a little
too much now to where they might think
about making that switch if things out
off to a rocky start good job holding
your question way to go take me inside
the coach's meeting because they meet
before the players right and the
quarterback coach or the offensive
coordinator listen man every time we go
out there he's going out there and he's
making plays and he's tearing it out
Lamar and yeah he's killing it right now
yeah how will they change minicamp
because of that will it change no I
don't think it's gonna change not gonna
get a more first team snap but it might
make an effort to I don't I don't know
about the first team snaps that depend
on where they are but I think they were
probably making more of an effort to
have a certain plan for him again just
to further along we're okay in so TAS
now it's minicamp we're gonna take the
training cam saw the training wheels off
a little bit so we're we're just gonna
put a little more on his shoulders see
how he reacts see how much we can push
the boundary just so they can
feel for one training camp and the
preseason does start to know how much
they can put on them my other question
for you is because it's Weddell does
that change your feeling about that
quote just to me it's credible
that's who feels more crowded yeah what
all's been around he's not the type of
guy that just throws around [ __ ]
either I mean he's pretty honest whether
it comes out I don't only I scream out
for a win and I don't when I lose
whatever it may be he's seems to have a
history of sharing some of the personal
things that go in with the locker room
and not being a BS sir it's interesting
the positive reports that I've seen thus
far Josh Allen and Lamar Jackson are
getting a lot of the positive reports
yeah
Baker you be the two most physically
gifted quarterbacks of the draft exact
yeah right but I've seen some really
good stuff from Rosen that he's grasping
the office really well but he's the
smartest guy
rosen's like not gonna get a darn 'old
store ya know I've heard more teddy than
Darnell Darnell it's been good I do know
that it's been good it hasn't been like
through their charts like awesome but I
think they're very happy with where
they're at I don't really know about the
Baker stuff a whole lot I can't tell you
anything there and I'll say with the
Rosen thing Rosen is gonna be one of
those guys that he's not gonna get truly
the credit he deserves until it becomes
you know preseason seven-on-seven
everyday all those things because
they're gonna see how surgical he can be
as a drop-back passer where sometimes at
this side to set up the physical prowess
can route us all right and right or I'm
in seven on seven and I've took an
unrealistic drop and I've hitched in the
pocket seven times and I threw an 80 or
a rifle down the field wow that got
everybody's attention but it's never
gonna happen in week seven in the NFL
right no the quarterback we're not
talking about that young the dragon el
dragón oh you have no idea I'm talking
about no clue that is the nickname of
Davis Webb quote Webb has been
outstanding Webb has the strongest arm
on the Giants roster and his flash
tremendous accuracy both during full
team 11 on 11 and seven on seven and a
show nice touch
Davis Webb well first of all saying he
is the strongest arm and the Giants
roster is not saying a whole lot there
just to be real here okay
I mean out of 32 starting quarterbacks
Eli's definitely at the bottom of
football
arm strength I'm not trying to be a jerk
we're just keeping a real here Letta who
they drafted yes certainly he is not a
guy that I watched on film it's at who
his arm gonna get him do you hi
he's a smart quarterback who has some
accuracy and has a very efficient
throwing motion it will never be
considered one of the better arms sold
Webb is in a great quarterbacks room to
look like the physical no doubt about it
yeah what do you think do we do we think
Davis Webb becomes at some point the
starting quarterback of the New York job
I mean I do think there's a chance yes I
do
again I would like to I would like to
seen him out there instead of Geno Smith
last year I get that but Ben McAdoo was
also trying to win a game and save his
career so he had to play a guy that he
felt could at least win a game so I do
think there's potential there you
remember our talks in the draft with
Davis Webb I mean Davis Webb was that
year I think I've I ranked him ahead of
DeSean Kaiser right didn't I I thought
it I did right at Cal he's got a he's a
decent little athlete and he's a big
body that can really throw the football
now I just need to see a little more
live bullets before I could say all the
rest but there's something there it's so
there's a large part of the Giants fan
base that really loves Davis Webb and
believe he's the guy yeah I know it's
he's got a lot of talk but III got to
see just a little more preceeds and
stuff to make that true evaluation
here's an interesting one Adrian
Peterson talking about Drew Brees being
up there in New Orleans just for that
short period of time and seeing him he
has clock worth clock work two hours
before practice going through
fundamentals he's in the weight room
he's lifting he's cut up one time and we
did our conditioning test it was
probably the first time I ever lost a
conditioning test so Drew Brees is in
better shape than Adrian Peterson mhm
were there guys when you got in better
shape but yes what does that mean no it
means that you know she does not can't
run the same race as the rhinoceros okay
have you had you beaten guys in the
conditioning test I'd be brandon
marshall eat that Brendan Marshall
because he has so much muscle that
coming down the last 50 yards his legs
had gotten so big and blown up because
we had a run 300 yards Edel's that he
couldn't even bend him he was like
running like he had wooden legs because
he was
again he's not the animal that was made
to run long distance so it would players
get upset when you would beat them yes
really but especially in Denver because
New England's the New England way and we
would run after practice I was the
quarterback I didn't have to run a lot
during practice so I wanna make I want
and I wanted to make it count I was I'm
willing to work I wanted to run so yeah
I would have guys like oh gosh damn I'm
break I Wes Lee Woodyard you know the
middle linebacker from Miami who went
there will it DJ Williams they would
hassle Mel will stay with how come
because I'd be in their group and I'd be
running with them and I'd and what what
kind of things would they say our Sims
trying to impress the coaches or and I
would you know I had to just start
yelling back like hey you know [ __ ] you
I haven't run all day I'm just trying to
get a workout in like I would just do
things like that
after time they realize like oh no this
is Chris he's psycho every day and he
runs as hard as he can because I'm more
of a bulldozer than a cheetah
I can I can workout forever I can run
for 740s until the Sun Goes Down for
seven four seven four seven for seven
yeah but those guys can run for four
four three four four and a few times yes
it starts to die up it's a different
wired animal altogether who got the most
upset when you would race against them I
mean if those guys always jumped out to
me at first where I just remember them
being there I was in all circles Sims yo
Johnny trihard and you know I would talk
crab and rose to Brady in the
conditioning test no no I don't I don't
think I actually saw them do the
conditioning test well the most
embarrassing conditioning test you saw
man well you know what happens a lot of
the times is the star players can weasel
their selves out of these things right I
don't who was it I some star on my
Denver team didn't make the conditioning
test and couldn't practice the like the
third day of practice because they
didn't do it I want to say it was Champ
Bailey but I might be wrong but I want
to be like who cares
I mean the [ __ ] come on nine Pro Bowls
in a row we're gonna see if he can do
the conditioning test to be out there
the conditioning test is the worst thing
about being a professional athlete and
football still works when you have to
take you're nervous it's training cam
your life is about to be over for a
month and here you go you know you're
about to be in this physical grind and
the first day you're gonna take away 80%
of my energy because you're gonna lock
me in a race and then you want me to
come out tomorrow and practice at full
speed all right so give me if you were
giving me that conditioning I would be
stressed in the summer at home in Jersey
I'd have my dad out in the field with me
like time me Dad I got a guy gonna run
three 300 yard shuttles and now that's
amazing about that every athlete in
every sport goes through the
conditioning test and we would start
basketball they call them Seventeen's
and you line up on one side line and I
have to go 17 times in a certain amount
of times right and that was like I don't
care how many times I practice this
I'm not [ __ ] getting it done I don't
have that I remember their day in high
school I did soccer for like three years
right and I transferred high schools and
they go here's the deal we have a
two-mile run that you have to get in and
in like under 15 and I was like seven
minute miles my brother still says that
my calf's are big because I trained that
whole summer for that one thing
conditioning tests every athlete at
every level and the fact that you're
telling me that NFL players dreaded it
makes me feel a lot better about myself
so what is the NFL conditioning test it
is it to ever the same for every team in
the NFL no it's not it's different and
if you were on the Titans Broncos and
patron yeah
in the Bucs yeah who had the hardest
conditioning I think the Broncos won
because the Bucs and the Titans had
things where if you did all your
workouts throughout the offseason you
didn't have to do the conditioning test
like you have to work out with them if
you were there for like let's say 95%
showing up rate right you would get
excused from the FIR and that would
drive people to go you know what I was
gonna say how much because of that but
that would be everything I'd be
literally waking up in the morning going
hey I don't think I'm gonna go today
it's just a Wednesday working out the
conditions I only
like three of these I can do you're
telling me that like dozens of offseason
workouts was worth more to you mentally
than a one condition
yes because I did not want to be at home
in my three or four weeks off worrying
about that or wasting my time training
for that that I was always like that's
not making me a better football player
my job is about four second explosions
why am i training for three minute runs
now so what was the Patriots
conditioning Patriots conditioning test
we had I think the year I was there was
just three 300 yards shuttles and a 300
your shuttle means a my starting on the
50 yes we did it and I'm running one way
and then back and the other way I'm back
and that's one I think yes so 300 yards
300 yards so I think we did we did it
two different ways I think we had to do
two of them the 50 yards 50 back 50 back
50 back right in how long I think it was
only one of them and my time was gosh
I'm so bad with the times you had all
different times for position groups
right so I was always with like running
backs on the linebackers that's where a
quarterback shirin right receivers and
DBS that their own group that was like
another level of running and I hold on
let me just think about it I want to say
300 yards shuttle
what would the time be I wanted me I
want to say like 2:30 maybe I was give
two and a half minutes to run 300 yards
yeah
for less than that I'm wrong it's
probably a minute and a half minute and
a half to run up yeah hit me or in a
second as I talk but the 50 back was not
bad what was bad is when you did 25 back
right that because the stop and start in
the turn is the race that's what kills
you
oh let me stop and plant my foot now I
got a restart and yes that's what get
your legs and your tony romo scooty
thighs and calves that your brothers
talking about that get them to blow up
and you should go holy cow I can't even
lift my legs anymore that was brutal
I was so nervous for that one in Denver
we ran it on the turf and yes I remember
I just had a few people where I was just
like I'm just gonna stay by him if I
stay by coral Buchalter ok ok I'm just
gonna stay he's a running back cuz he'll
make it and I'll be good and that's what
I did and I made it but I was so those
are some of the most nervous points of
my career I mean
Briona game right not the playoffs no
brandon marshall coming up to me in the
last one going how should i attack this
one and I'm sitting there like laughing
because again it's like our old LeBron
talk the freakiest guys have the hardest
times with these tests because they are
so muscled up and have no body fat
percentage that their bodies burn out
and these type of long distance run
rights OTO might not even pass the
condition a hard time it'd be very hard
right those guys have a hard time and
and I remember Brandon Marshall going
like what should i do should i pace
myself to have a strong finish or should
I just come out ball and I go I don't
think you're gonna have anything left if
you just pace yourself for the finish I
know you might as well just come all out
and he was coming all out and he got it
done I could still see him running at me
the last like 30 yards like straight leg
running he couldn't lift his legs but
that was one and then other teams do
sprinting where like my dad he had a
year where they had had run ten 40s all
within 2/10 of their 40 time that they
ran at their fastest in mini camp right
so the like if you ran a four seven and
we wonder why these guys get hurt
because they haven't practiced and the
most intimidating exhausting workout
likely of the entire offseason is on
their first day back a little crazy it's
stupid if they were smart you would go
there's other scientific ways to see if
somebody is conditioned right for I know
I don't think it's let's see if time is
it I know you can test their urine you
can test their blood you can weigh them
you can check body fat or you could just
have other exercises that aren't so
taxing the smart teams do it and then
you get a day off and then you have
practice or whatever maybe I don't even
know I'm just saying that would be the
smart way to do it it's to them I think
my year with Denver we did test the next
day I think we just had meetings and
walkthroughs and then the next day after
that we had practice yeah and that was
okay now you're giving your guys a time
to read you know cooperate and get their
body going can you imagine
hungover for the conditioning tada I
couldn't imagine anything I mean I've
been hung over for one practice in my
life really and it was in high school
that crazy Christopher idea crazy we're
gonna call big [ __ ] right that's all
right it's what hat what practice on my
sophomore year first day before two days
I'm getting to know my wife she's part
of the problem here my snoring wife yeah
good old good old Danielle she I'm just
meeting her and I of course liked her
girl she's the new girls school she
moved back from Florida and it's the
summertime and I go over her house with
another buddy on my team and another
girl and we're hanging out and I'm
planning on leaving cuz I have to it is
the next morning somehow shots of
Bacardi and Chris can't drink at 37 let
alone at 18 or 17 or out of all that was
and this is a constant reminder that if
you're under the age of 21 don't drink
alcohol and I drank Bacardi Bacardi Rum
which to this day I can't even smell or
it makes me fun that one night I drank
Bacardi and I didn't know what I was
doing I just kept drinking shots you're
like it hasn't hit me yet and all of a
sudden oh man I was this your first time
drinking no no it wasn't my first time
it's probably my first time hard liquor
drinking and being drunk like that so I
my mom has to come pick me up that night
she picks if she knows I'm like messed
up and she's like okay honey just go up
to your bed and you know I hope you wake
up and you're okay in the morning I woke
up and it was like I had a 18-wheeler on
my head okay
and I had to go to practice and I go to
practice it's a hot day it's my first
day at two-a-days and I'm miserable and
I got through and then we got a water
break like halfway through and of course
I'm dehydrated I'm so thirsty
I drank like 40 cups of water I was cool
and it all came back up when I had to
say the next play to start practice
together I'm getting the huddle and I'm
like you know bunch right and I got
waterfall just came out but man I felt
good after that I was good you down the
thing down high school practice yeah I
saw it done I'm gonna do that Burson -
oh it wasn't a yeah that was a second
right right he did the Super Bowl now
he's accused of doing in the Super Bowl
there is no video evidence some
teammates say it happens
team say it doesn't many people believe
that the Tampa Bay Bucs won is confused
for the Super Bowl one that was amazing
I was major I lost my spleen so I wasn't
playing I was just sitting on the
sidelines first of all we were up 20 to
nothing yes and you came back because of
westburg Brian Westbrook wasn't was it
was one of those days where Donovan was
this the Keane that they lost in the
Matt Bryant 16 yard it was that game
yeah Brian Westbrook literally won the
game too soon it was exactly right he
broke a screen where he literally like
everybody on the team missed twice he
was like we're gonna work down the field
slowly and then Westbrook's like or I
could go 67 yards to the house yes wait
but when did the vomit head like that
one of those last drives so they were
down 20 then nothing they scored two
touchdowns pretty quick and it was like
oh crap it's a game I can look about
together the ball back holy cow and
Donovan I mean it was a frantic pace is
a hot day and you could tell Donovan he
was in his like Nissan you know hands on
his knees in between plays like I was
like all he is exhausted and he gets
underneath Center and he's calling the
play and all sudden he just backs away
and pukes right in between the guard in
the center and I can remember seeing
like demons alive and like getting up
first second being like oh like and then
get back down into the three point
stands and getting ready and a few plays
I thought yeah he threw the screen and
Westbrook it was one of those Donovan
days though where he couldn't hit a pass
between five and 20 yards but he could
hit it if it was 70 or if it was minus
seven behind the line of scrimmage for a
screen it was only two throws he can
make if it was an amazing throw he can
hit it it was a child throw he could hit
it anything in between he couldn't hit
the broadside of the barn and that is
the reason you're like so conflicted
with the doubt I mean it's a tough one
because he's like the worst great
quarterback ever at him and Eli it's
what I always say there's some of the
worst great quarterbacks ever
he threw such a beautiful 50-yard ball
but I've never seen someone skip 7 yard
passes as consistently as oh yeah I know
it's amazing
donning they have and Eli are the top of
your best worst quarter action worst
best quarterbacks worst bombers the best
quarterbacks yes because who else is in
that list who else comes to mind
Ivan Kerr wonders on that list
Wow yeah I do I mean yeah at first best
worst best you like that phrase I'm
trying to also think who the best worst
quarterbacks would be like Sean Hill
yeah well the best worst quarterbacks
ever you got a duck start yours less
than 70 koi Detmer start your 70 list
the I got one question for you this is
from Kawika borough you're starting a
franchise this was an Instagram thing
and you have to pick these five
positions who is your number one guy at
these five positions on defense
defensive end outside linebackers so
outside pass rusher you get one in the
NFL who are you picking one health team
fence event outside linebacker edge pass
rusher let me pull up the team pull up
the team's hmm I think it would be hard
I think for me I would probably go with
Khalil Mack / Vaughn is that the battle
I think I would I would rather have the
little bit of size and power Khalil has
over Vaughn and the age helps a little
to get one defensive tackle oh man
sucks I'm going to take Fletcher Cox
that's the kind of detail / Aaron
Donald's most people are going to take
Aaron Donald and I understand that I'm
just saying for the christams defense I
would rather have the Fletcher Cox you
get one linebacker right middle the D ya
middle of the day hmm let's see
are we thinking of here no but yeah the
CJ Mosley's of the world I'm just trying
to think if I don't miss anybody here
man
shazier talbin smith shazier it was up
there for me of course until the injury
yep man okay hold on I'm almost there
I'm just cycling through here just say
anything okay hello how are you man
Barre and Kendricks woo that's I mean to
me you get one when I get in this
conversation I'm just gonna Whittle it
down for you right just to its Wagner
its Wagner it's bar and Kendricks it is
key
it is our Deon Jones I don't think I'm
putting anybody there I think I'm gonna
go with Anthony bar
Anthony bar is your tongue as you're
lying back I think I would Wow yeah I'm
a big fan Anthony bar sideline to
sideline size and ability the length and
athleticism and past coverage I think
are pretty top-notch and it's the reason
they gave him a new contract right there
figuring another figure it out right
cornerback
you get one I'm going with my man John
Ramsey yeah Jalen which is cool he's
working out with his dad right as they
said he's doing all yeah and you get one
safety Oh like when I went right to
Landon Collins in my head who was the
other safety I'm missing you know our
keynote Niels the man yes he is I love
me some piano anybody else said I'm
missing you thinking the top of your
head I don't think the Seahawk guys
still apply anymore no I don't think so
either I put a Harrison Smith in there
he's in that combo but I don't think I
quite am I McCourty Jamal Adams oh damn
man that's a tough one too yeah I think
I I think I'm gone who you go who you
say once Jamal Adams yeah I think I went
on Denver no nope I think I'm gonna go I
think I would go Landon Collins as the
number one safety I think I would Jamal
Adams is in that convo yeah no Neil you
did say I love Kia no LaMarcus Joyner
yaar in Matthew
undersized for me those guys that's why
I leave them off I think so you have
answered that the top guy at these
positions for you right now building
your defense
Khalil Mack Fletcher Cox Anthony bar
Jalen Ramsey Landon Collins sounds good
I just feel good I feel pretty good
about that the safety one I'm just
trying to think if there's anybody out
some all Adams is in that combo he is
that special a rue 811 one our
suggestion for mascot battle for
Wednesday okay pick one or two hmm I
fooled you last week because you thought
I'd pick two
I used to be number two and that's right
but don't hold their I don't even think
about it okay I find I'm going number
two then number two you are a San
Francisco 49er I am a Pittsburgh Steeler
oh we're gonna be fighting each other
the same tool stealer
versus a 49er yeah a room mine's gonna
have a sharp sharp end to it though
you're just gonna have a blunt and like
just big hammer blunt force trauma yeah
simply Davey would like to Wis his
cousin [ __ ] you Dan so that one's for
them and then it will end on this
question this is a reddit question from
best holy paladin you have a time
machine that can go back to 1970 and you
may bring two currently active NFL
players with you one on offense one on
defense so Oh a 70 man 1970 you're going
back in time and you get to bring one
offensive guy and one defensive guy who
are you bringing that's old
these guys will undoubtedly you could
either go with somebody on offense
that's super fast super big well the
best player offensively right then at
that point it would probably be Joe
Namath right who was just a recent Super
Bowl MVP I'm just trying to what blows
their mind more let's let me break it
down like this right you walk in you go
here's our new quarterback Aaron Rodgers
kind of the same size as Joe Namath you
know anybody gets out there they're like
holy [ __ ] or this is David Johnson and
they're like what the hell is this thing
or here's Julio Jones and they look at
him and they go how are we supposed to
guard him
or here's Tyre and Smith and they go
this is what humans look like in 48
years so what what do you think would
cause the most surprised because Antonio
Brown I think they think wow you're
really good but Julio I think the whole
er David Johnson one of the ones where
they'd be like what I mean David
Johnson's bigger than Jim Brown or Cam
Newton Oh Dan that would probably blow
people away we
well would because I think the
quarterback position naturally they'd
look at him and go wow
but you think Cam Newton over holy Oh
David or Tyron Smith I think it's
between Julio and David I think Julio
probably wins out you pick Julio I think
like a know down because who was there
gonna be ike man Julio is as big as some
of our defense ends and our middle
linebackers and he's faster than all of
us defensively yeah do you look at a
Fletcher Cox do you look at an Aaron
Donald do you look at a Von Miller do
you look at an Anthony bar is Jalen
Ramsey talking all that [ __ ] back at
1970 you know what I mean yes I do I
know I've the door are you finding a an
in-demand soo that's right I was you're
also gonna say like you know the Khalil
max of the world would be they would be
like man they they build people like you
and that package that's why I was saying
Aaron Dom yeah right it's same kind of
thing where you're just like you're not
that big but you're stronger than all of
us in every position how the hell is
that so you'd probably be one of those
two because those are the type of guys
where I think it's like you look at them
and you go out there pretty unbelievably
built but once they move and they start
to push you a little bit you go what the
hell like they're like made of steel
I've also thought about what if you took
back like an Edelman and they were like
oh come on in you look just like us
they're like what the hell is this guys
quick as hell that's my 1970s voice we
didn't really pick two though did we I
said Joe Namath and then who's the
defensive guy we're gonna pick like I
was thinking like Ray Nitschke no no no
you're bringing guys back tight oh I
thought you were saying I had to just
pick somebody and from the centos know
your your time traveling with two people
back to 70 yeah so you're bringing Julio
and Khalil Mack I think so Julio and
quail I would really want to bring like
Reggie White but we're talking about
current players current yeah yeah white
came back today he would impress people
oh yeah he would
hey but still yes yeah he Jose he was a
guy that was truly 30 to 40 years ahead
of his time yeah like Jim bro
yeah like Lawrence Taylor was a
linebacker right like I mean lawyers
know people like Lawrence Taylor when he
got in the league now there's a Khalil
Mack and that type of body almost on
every team it is while
now guys thank you so much as always hit
us up on social at Sims and left go
continue to subscribe on iTunes leave a
five star review we appreciate it it
will be Steeler vs. diner on Wednesday
we'll have big Phil and we're gonna have
the disc assessment we can see what if I
get Shanahan to come in and stick up for
me with the 49er I just win the battle
right away if you get Kyle Shanahan to
come on we'll see Phil's a very
honorable judge and of course we're
gonna have more information about where
you guys can get the Sims 70 shirt the
only shirt with the first 70
quarterbacks perfectly ranked according
to Chris Sims rankings yes you excited
about that we got some swag it's
delicious we'll have that old Wednesday
guys for Sims peace out homey for
federic goodies and for the lef koe man
I'm working on not interrupting you did
yesterday you did good I appreciate
you're all grown up see you guys on
Wednesday
[Music]